as positive cases were going up and
things were moving fast down during the
pandemic the las vegas strip
turned dark now the lights and sounds in
one of the busiest streets in the world
took a break we fast forward one year
later now and we can see
a different picture and some hope on the
horizon las vegas strip resorts are
opening again
and downtown is coming back to life as
well joe muller spoke to
some people who work there and he joins
us live from fremont street and the las
vegas boulevard
joe well it's definitely a different
look this year compared to last year on
st
patrick's day i'll give you a live look
here at fremont street experience a lot
of people wearing green coming out to
having a good time
it's been a tough it's been tough for
businesses around the valley and
especially here in downtown where there
are
so many restaurants and bars now take a
look at this video from last year
as the virus became a reality businesses
were forced to close
some even boarding up doors and windows
downtown las vegas
and along fremont street looks like a
ghost town this is video shot from our
aviator drone
businesses laid off employees and people
scrambled to get unemployment benefits
throughout the past year some places
reopened with limited capacities but
this week they were given the green
light to have 50 percent capacity today
places are celebrating for st patrick's
day having specials
i spoke to dustin hoots from evil pie
shop
he's glad to see people returning to the
area
i mean a year ago we gave away like 300
pizzas when we were shutting down
so it's nice seeing it all come back and
i don't know the fact that it's on st
patrick's day works out pretty well so
the jobs are getting fun again down here
i have seen a lot of people out today
wearing green and celebrating tourists i
spoke with said it isn't as busy as
vegas usually is like they like it
but it's nice to see people enjoying
themselves many are hopeful for the
future
with the vaccine now back out here live
you're taking a look at fremont street
experience once again a lot of people
are out here celebrating that
that employee we spoke with at the pizza
shop earlier today also says he's
noticing more people wearing their
their mask and uh following the cobin 19
protocols which he says
is hopeful for the future he doesn't
want to go backwards with this pandemic
or any shutdown so he's hoping
eventually we can get back to 100 and
that's your turn reporting live here
on fremont street experience joe mullen
eight news now